in countless this is a mid Suffolk
cabinet meeting and this meeting will be
broadcast live to YouTube and will be
capable of repeated viewing the entirety
of the meeting will be filmed
except for confidential or exempt items
if you attend the meeting in person you
will be deemed to have consented to
being filmed and that the images and
sound recordings could be used for
webcasting and training purposes the
council members of the public and the
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
item one apologies for absence
declarations of interest by councillors
mca 19/20 to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 28th of august page
one two three four five six seven
thank you can I have a seconder Thank
You councillor flatten and show of hands
please thank you
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
screen item 5 questions by councillors
none received item 6 matters referred by
the overview and scrutiny or the joint
audit and standards committee there were
no item 7 decisions list just for noting
has anybody got any comments no Thank
You counsel
item 8 mca 19/20 1 the corporate plan as
colleagues on the cabinet are aware
we've been working on a cross-party
basis with our cabinet colleagues our
Baber
to review the existing joint strategic
plan before it expires in 2020 this work
and the principles we have developed to
guide the evolution of the corporate
plan are set out in Appendix A the
senior leadership team have been
supporting us in this work and it has
also been significantly informed by
officers from across both councils I'm
therefore really proud at now to be
presenting this new joint corporate plan
2019 to 2027 for recommendation on to
full council of course the nature and
role of district councils has not
fundamentally changed the new corporate
plan therefore reflects more of an
evolution rather than a revolution it
does however provide a more stretching
joint vision for the future of our areas
and is designed to enable us to address
the challenges and seize the
opportunities facing our districts and
our councils for the foreseeable future
the revised mission a new mission
statement will ensure that we provide
more confident leadership of our places
through greater place-based working
our internet interconnected strategic
priorities are now firmly enshrined as
being the environment our economy
housing well-being our customers and our
communities
finally by embedding our newly adopted
values within the corporate plan we are
more deeply rooting our organization in
what we believe in genuinely caring
about our residents and places and
getting stuff done for people a
visualization of the revised corporate
plan is contained within the report but
I have asked that the chief executive
provides a more detailed PowerPoint
presentation when this comes forward for
debate at Council I therefore take great
pleasure in moving the recommendation at
paragraph 3.1 the cabinet recommends the
draft corporate plan 2019 to 2027 to
Council as visually represented in
paragraph four point five to replace the
refreshed joint strategic plan 2016 to
2020 and I call for a seconder thank you
I think I'm I'm sure yes I'm very happy
to second this Thank You Council
Brewster has anybody got any questions
councillor Ellen Thank You chair
I'm just got some questions on paragraph
8 1 & 8 to the development of the
corporate plan has been informed by the
engagement and consultation has taken
place
could I ask with whom it suffered in
terms of councillors other than the
administration
what other consultation has there been
and in what form and also in 8 2 you say
there has not therefore been any direct
consultation with the public has there
been any indirect consultation with the
public or any direct consultation with
anyone yeah anybody else and I have one
of the quick query that's on 10 one
where you say there are no immediate
environmental implications well I would
have hoped that adopting a corporate
plan would have significant
environmental implications hopefully
positive ones
the public has not been consulted on
this the cabinet's the joint cabinets
for baby and mid Suffolk have all been
consulted and contributed to this plan
and on the environmental implications of
course there's going to be implications
but we're not in a position to monitor
those until the environment strategy and
the task force come back to us with
their recommendations and this is a
living document it will progress as the
life of the council changes over the
next four years
councillor even thank you very much
chair this is a document that's going to
last for eight years 2019 to 2027 it's
been a agreed by seven conservative
members in mid Suffolk and has had no
input at all from anybody other than
those seven conservatives given that the
small number of people that is that is
doing that I've got grave concerns that
it actually suits what the council is
trying to achieve in the past we've had
strategic plans where we've had
workshops we've had roundtable sessions
with counselors across Baber
and it suffered we worked with our Baber
colleagues and amongst all of us we have
produced a very effective working
relationship that at the end of that
result has been able to be modified by
the Conservative administration as they
saw fit but at the centre it had the
consultation and no member of this
council was able then to say I wasn't
involved because they were this is a
corporate plan as I said for eight years
with only seven conservatives seven
conservatives putting their input into
it I would if I had the time be able to
actually ask each of them in turn what
their input was and then we'll be doing
that at a later stage
so what consultation is that this stage
come to a cabinet I appreciate you said
it's going to go to full counsel but but
this is already a public document they
see you say it's a living document but I
doesn't say that within the within this
document before us so my questions are
why has there is there only the seven of
you actually been involved at this stage
and what will be the consultation with
members asides besides from actually a
debate at full council which as you are
fully aware becomes more party political
whereas a workshop is not to workshop is
much more consensus building Thank You
chair this is a recommendation to go to
Council for presentation and end
discussion it's quite a high level it's
not at the detailed level of a workshop
any other questions before we move into
the debate
Kancil wiped it I just feel for the
record that this cabinet is not seven
conservative members but it's six
conservatives and one proud independent
that should be making the record I think
and this is an administration plan and I
have got to me just one thing I would
like to change which is section 12 I
would like to see added on to that list
of background documents the RIT strategy
and also add joint local plan the joint
local plan is referenced elsewhere but
it's crucial that our emerging joint
local plan is listed you may try yes
just by technical question it's at
section 10 is environmental implications
so in section 10 section 10 is
environmental implications but legal
implications and financial implications
are further earlier on the document
could could you I asked the in future
for any reports it's got financial
implications then illegal implications
then then then environmental and then
you lead on to the rest of the report
it's just rather than tacking on
environmental implications at the end do
you see what I mean the actual report
layout I'm happy to go and talk about
that with our democratic services but
these templates are already set up in
one gov but I will I will discuss it
with them
cancer Fleming also is about number ten
environmental implications so just a
question maybe for you Arthur in the
past
environmental implications this whole
paragraph has been to see whether
whatever is being was the subject of the
report might have a negative impact on
the environment it's to pick things up
that you know might be overlooked am I
wrong in that so by I think what we're
doing here or what councillor Yvonne is
seeking to do is to actually change the
context of use of this whole paragraph
I'm putting this out because I I don't
have enough experience to know where the
environmental implications paragraph
originated from or why I think it'll be
quite useful to understand that and if
we are changing there to understand and
I'm moving its position then it has a
different context in the whole document
assessment process um so the with all of
those sections whether it's the
environmental implications or the
financial implications and such like
it's not so much a necessarily a case of
saying are there negative implications
of this of this approach it's simply
asking the question of when looked at
specifically in the financial aspect or
when looked at specifically the
environmental aspect what are the
potential implications of taking this
approach and you would expect that for
example if there were significant
negative or positive implications in
relation to any of those then how they
may or may not be mitigated accordingly
particularly if those were negative ones
so in variant in relation to the
environmental implications the reason
why it's saying there are no immediate
environmental implications from adopting
the the approach from the doctor the
corporate plan is because all this is in
that regard is adopting the corporate
plan the
locations clearly would flow through
from the environment /t as the leaders
referred to and the task force work that
would follow later equally you could
turn it the other way around and you
could say that there are some
environments and implications by virtue
of adopting this corporate plan given
that the environment has a strong
component part within the corporate plan
itself but clearly it's impossible at
this stage to really flesh out as the
leader said that the detail that sits
beneath councilor burn thank you
might've gentleman um yes perhaps I can
throw a little bit of light on where
environmental implications came from it
it was something that the previous
administration I think in particular
myself and you know it came out of a
workshop for a little task force task
and finish group that suggested
environmental implications should form a
part of every report which it now does
at that time we did put together a
guidance document for officers that
indicated what it was we expected them
to consider when answering this
particular question so that guidance
document presumably still exists and is
accessible if members would like to see
a copy of it I'm sure I just also wanted
to say to to councilor even that whilst
it is certainly true that there's not
been any direct consultation with the
public regarding the revised corporate
plan I point out that we are all in
contact with our residents all the
members of the cabinet and we talk to
them
that's the indirect consultation that
has gone into it it is informed not just
by the opinions of the individual
cabinet members but by the informed view
on their community's needs
and requirement thank you just to
confirm in relation to the question from
Caliban yes absolutely rights there is a
guidance document and a checklist that's
used or applied when looking up how to
complete the sections within the reports
specifically around environmental
implications that's right and can we can
we see that so you might have a chairman
if I might just absolutely is this then
a joint corporate plan and it's after
how it should be referred to yes it's
certainly been produced as being a joint
corporate plan form itself again for
Baylor jointly in that regard yes I've
got a proposer and a seconder can I have
a show of hands in favor
or against
all upstate
character thinking
item 9 mca 19/20 - is the bottles Dale
and Ricky horn neighborhood plan
canceled Burn Center the report before
you today updates cabinet on the
progress of the bottle sailin drinking
all neighborhood plan and sets out two
recommendations one that the Parish
Council modify their plan in accordance
with examiner recommendations and two
subject to satisfactory completion of
the above the plan be advanced to a
referendum now this report follows the
same format as others that come before
that have come before Kevin's in recent
months but with the examiners
modifications of note now move to
paragraph four point five paragraph four
point one four reminds us that if this
plan receives a majority yes vote at the
local referendum the District Council is
obliged to adopt this neighborhood plan
as part of our development plan
framework I can also report that
officers are now working with the parish
council and that this plan is being
modified in accordance with the
examiner's report that work should be
completed soon in other words the parish
council are addressing the first
recommendation this bottle zone Ricky
Hall neighborhood plan becomes the
seventh such plan in mid Sabich to be
presented to members for approval and go
forward to a local referendum
I commend this plan to you and ask that
cabinet endorse the recommendations set
out and report Thank You mayor call for
a seconder cancel Fleming thank you
does anybody have any questions
that's a whitehead oh I might be wrong
but I think previous neighborhood plans
have been single Parrish neighborhood
plans where this is a this involves more
than one parish am i right in thinking
that there was obviously separate ballot
boxes but when they counted to load the
mix together so it's not clear because
it's one plus 50% and at least pass this
plan but it won't be clear to anyone in
terms of how the various parishes of 30
I think I can answer that but I will get
one of our officers to confirm that it
will be a referendum of all residents
within the neighborhood area as
designated which therefore means that it
will be yes may be single to to two
polling stations to ballot boxes but the
old votes will be counted together but
can I just ask in which case what if
everybody from one parish votes and
everybody from another parish doesn't
provided the fifty percent or fifty one
percent of the total votes cast even if
all those votes come from one one of the
two parishes then their effort the plan
will be put forward for making at the
next council meeting at the next four
council meeting does anybody have
council Brewster Thank You mo yeah yeah
I think I think my question probably
more or less sort of in there is yours
but not quite and following referendum
when the neighborhood plans come back to
Council we receive details of the
percentage vote in favor or against
although it make no difference I wonder
if for information in future we could
receive details of turnout for the just
to provide complete transparency
I think the answered hurt is yes thank
you yes we can I talk to electoral
services colleagues and well-well
arrange it so that you'll see that the
total yes/no vote and the breakdown as
requested Thank You councillor Burton
well just correct me if I'm wrong but I
think we have actually shown turnout in
some of the returns so far so the when
we declare the results for the neighbor
planned referendum it's the total number
of yes votes no votes other votes cast
and also details of the number of people
vote and therefore the percentage of
turn out against the electorate so that
is on the decoration results and as
councillor Brewster's arts will we're
trying to separate that between botties
Dale and Ricky Hall Elizabeth thank you
so I've got a proposer and a seconder
[Applause]
can I have a show of hands in favor
show of hands against
carried
item 10 mca 19/20 3 development of
building services business plan cancer
platinum thank you chair I'd like to
move recommendations and three point one
and three point two and three point
three just an introduction to the report
I refer you to NCA 1923 the performance
and success of the build of building
services is an organizational priority
when tenants consider great service they
generally generally relate it to their
home a good speedy repair service is
seen as the most important and
significant reason to rate their service
from social housing provider as great as
members we have set the expectation that
the building service is high-performing
delivering a high quality service which
provides value for money however our
current service does not always meet
these expectations there may never be a
good time to review the surface but it
is important that we plan ahead we must
consider whether the service we offer is
financially sound and others the best
service provision to our residents we
need to consider the options there are
of providing building services in an
alternative way to help us meet the
challenges we may face in the future
there are local and national challenges
we must consider local challenge
challenges include the financial
pressures in maintaining maintaining and
delivering services and the views and
opinions of our residents captured
through the 2019 survey of tenants and
residents national challenges such as
the residents expectations or the
likelihood of significantly more
regulation in the future the social
housing green paper and the Hackett
review a report commissioned by the
government following the tragic
brownfield
how far to make recommendations on the
future regulatory system must also be
considered we are keen to learn from
others to get accelerate the progression
of the service as a result this paper
sets out a timetable to develop business
case which explores the opportunity of
developing a joint venture to delivering
building services with flagship housing
which if agreed today would see a robust
business case be presented to our
cabinet in the spring of 2020 I wish to
propose the recommendations set out in
three point 103.2 of the report and
would ask for a second a second
counselor whitehead Thank You Misha t'v
come forward and therefore very happy to
secondly recommendations thank you does
anybody have any questions I've got two
questions just the first is a point of
clarity really in paragraph two point
three the end of the first sentence and
then which refers to two possible
options outsourcing the service or
finding an alternative partner and with
both of which have been discounted
because there are newer more because
there are no immediate opportunities can
I can reaffirm the officer just confirm
that the first option which would favor
sorry
exploring the opportunities that a joint
venture would create to deliver building
services is not exclusive of the
discounted option referred to in
paragraph two point three I just want to
make sure there's no conflict in
language there
mixture Thank You counselor Flatman in
answer to your question the option was
considered there were a number of
options that we've considered before
presenting to cabinet today the
preferred option of developing a joint
venture with flagship housing so those
options are just a continuation of the
current service in its current form and
obviously you'll be aware of some of the
reasons why we don't feel that that is
beneficial to do that right now based on
the financial pressures around
delivering that service and just the
speed of change in terms of the amount
of work that we want to do and carry out
to improve the service that residence
receives and by doing that on our own
it's going to take longer in the report
under 4.20
there's a table which just sets out a
high level the options so option one was
the continuation of the current service
option two is outsourcing and
outsourcing is something that
historically has been in vogue at
certain periods of time but outsourcing
we've ruled out because aid the market
and market conditions don't lend itself
to probably I'm not asking for is very
short and it's just to be clear that
what we're actually recommending is to
explore the opportunities that joint
venture would create deliver building
services that's fine but at the same
time we are by implication ruling out
any other partner other than flagship is
that correct but we just need I'm just
looking for clear language there okay
yes that's of course you have implied in
two point three that to finding an
alternative partner to enter into a
joint venture with an alternative
partner to whom and in three point one
we don't say that we are looking to
explore opportunities with to create a
joint venture with flagship and I think
that's probably what we mean I just
wonder if you could clarify that yeah
apologies
any confusion with regards to the
options there is the option of joint
venture and in the report under 4.20
there are the two options of a joint
venture with flagship which we've
defined as our preferred option and a
joint venture with any other public
partner and the reason we've ruled out
that is because we don't have a
relationship with anyone and no one has
presented as being a suitable partner at
this stage I recommendation three point
one is to explore the opportunities
there's a joint venture with flagship
with that that's what it should say then
really okay thank you for that I've got
one more question and that is in
paragraphs four point two two and four
point two three
um can you explain you know what's meant
there please you just say that again
page twenty five paragraphs four point
two two and four point two three
could you explain what that means those
paragraphs me yep
certainly um it just explains who
flagship group are and flagship are made
up of a number of subsidiaries so the
reference to our ft is what was known as
right first time and is their repairs
and maintenance arm of the business so
when we refer to flagship group that the
joint venture would be with flagship
group but they do have a number of
separate entities that we may contract
with through the joint venture so in
addition to our ft which is repairs and
maintenance for example they have a
subsidiary called gas way which provides
their repairs and make gas servicing
okay now just wasn't sure if they hadn't
been introduced before so we thought
maybe it was a typographical error we
could just for the record clarify that
our ft service is part of the flagship
group because it isn't apparent from the
paper thank you yes we'll do that and I
have a question
regarding so the table on 4.20 you've
got options one to four there but we're
only looking at option three options one
two and four been discounted and we're
talking about flagship group are picking
up the costs for the business case but
at the bottom of page six twenty six so
flagship approved creating a business
case that tells us that we ought to be
having a joint venture with then the
bottom of page 26 if we don't go with
what they recommend we have to pay for
it so in answer to the question chair
the development of the business case
will be a joint piece of work between
babe and mid Suffolk and flagship it's
going to be that the business case is
about a joint venture and so therefore
that work will be developed in
cooperation so that will be people like
myself and colleagues in building
services working with colleagues from
flagship housing and we will develop a
business case one business case for
consideration by labor cabinet and mid
Suffolk cabinet next year and by
flagships Board there are costs in in
regards to they are going to provide
officer assistance for two days per week
between now and the development of the
business case there may be a small cost
if for example in two months time we
said actually we don't want we don't
want consider this business case any
further we've changed our mind for
whatever reason then there would be some
cost incurred just from an officer time
from their perspective but that that's
the only cost in regards to flagship
housing this says will include will will
incur flagship group costs you mean
close to them yeah they're up there
officer time if they're deployed an
officer into to our organizations for
two days a week to develop the business
case alongside me if in two months time
we decide that we didn't want to do that
then there'd be of course
application in terms of their officer
time that's been invested in the
business case I in terms of development
of this success that's obviously not
something that we would be considering
we're enlisted to develop the business
case and present a business case to
members next year I would expect the
cost to be minimal anyway I think the
clarity and transparency I would like to
see those quantified council reburn
thank you Joe I think two members of the
cabin have questions but as dr. Tate
John to take the cabinet questions
before me sorry thank you Jeff at you
before you ask your question about but
leaders program you you've asked most of
it but it was a clarification of this
point about what were any of the
business development cost at flagships
own risk which wouldn't be quite a
normal thing going into arrangement like
this and the the only other that in the
answer you've given that and I hear
they're the only costs of those related
to an officer time that they are
providing though now other costs
business development costs it they're
occurring that we might be liable for
terms that unless our second question
was not to be pessimistic but if this
doesn't work out what's the plan okay so
in answer to that question as part of
development the business case there's a
need to sign non-disclosure agreements
and there's a need to sign a memorandum
of understanding in regards to that
memorandum memorandum of understanding
there is a note there's a figure of
10,000 pounds for which we would have to
reimburse if we didn't proceed with the
joint venture and but that is not
proceeding with a joint venture based on
a
it's presented as a sound business case
so actually the cost to meet Suffolk is
five thousand pounds I see that as as a
small amount of money in in comparison
to the commitment that flagship we
couldn't provide flagship will be
providing officer time in relation to
supporting myself and colleagues to
write the business case but there's also
the added value so over the next few
months we'll be working with the
flagship group around a whole range of
challenges that we currently face so for
example one of those may be around the
fact that we need to procure a new fleet
for that building services ready for
next year they have a fleet manager we
may take soundings from them about how
they've procured they're fully the type
of vehicles they're using are they using
electric what other challenges that
they've found using electric for example
for an example so actually we're gonna
get a lot of added value from from that
that relationship in terms of your
second question in terms of in terms of
your second question in terms of what
what next if the joint venture doesn't
doesn't equate to a sound business case
well the what next is a continuation of
the service in the in its current form
and that work will continue whilst the
business case is being developed and I
want to stress that the business case is
an isolated piece of work that will go
on in the background the product for me
is to continue to provide the service
residents expect and demand and you can
see from the satisfaction results that
we're not always getting it right and
satisfaction is reducing so we will
continue with an action plan to improve
the service because if the joint venture
isn't isn't sound then we've still got
to deliver that service so I don't want
to be 6 or 9 months behind where I could
be in terms of development service
developing the culture and developing
some of the the actions that we've got
around wouldn't be health and safety or
the way that we deliver the business so
for example the scheduling software
which will enable the customer access
point to give a customer a precise time
and day when the repair will be carried
out will continue and will be
implemented
this year because it's the right thing
to do and it improves the business going
forward councillor Flatman yes
councillor Fleming is just just wants
clarification on the recommendations
here because it says that a business
case is developed by officers which
explores the opportunities of a joint
venture on on the table for proposed
timeline we've got October 20 19 20 20
lag flagship will support the service
and develop a draft business case with
officers from Baber
and mid Suffolk and she's just worried
that the two are conflicting but the
recommendation 3.1 and over on the table
for proposed timeline and the October 20
19 20 20 and it says flagship will
support the service and develop off a
draft business case
so she's just worrying that it looks as
if it's a calm you know conflict of
interest there okay
clarify my concern is who's developing
the business case is it flagship or us
annoyed and if it's if flagship is to be
you know the firm we work with is it
right that they'd also developed the
business case so you're asking exactly
the same questions that I asked and I
can absolutely understand the concern
which is they would say that wouldn't
they I suppose is that is the risk
having said that that would be the case
if we were solely asking somebody to
provide a business case as to why they
should work with us and that isn't the
case this is being done jointly there is
as much chance at the end of this
process the flagship say this doesn't
work for us and they walk away as there
is this that you might say this doesn't
work for us and we walk away so there's
equal stake in that regard clearly
they're not going to enter into
something that doesn't work for them and
the same way that you won't enter into
something that doesn't work for you I
think just coming back to a question
councillor good answer asked earlier as
well in terms of if not this then what
it depends what the outcome of this is
to be perfectly honest because if this
demonstrates that the model and I don't
like to get hung up on models but if it
if it demonstrates that the model of a
joint ventures is the correct one but
the business working relationships are
such or the mechanics are such that it
doesn't work with flagship then I would
say I wouldn't use these expressions
normally the plan B would be to look for
an alternative joint venture if the
answer comes back and says actually the
model is wrong for whatever reason then
clearly that wouldn't be the option so
it's not a helpful answer I know but the
answer is it depends but just to give
some reassurance this is us in
conjunction with flagship jointly
developing a business case that needs to
work ultimately for us and for them so
that there is no conflict of interest
there that's why the financial position
is such that yes there's some risk that
they're taking but they're not entirely
taking it we're not paying for it
because again that would be even more so
more concerning if you like in the sense
that we're paying somebody to produce
something that you know what's gonna say
in that regard that isn't the case so if
if they walk away do we still pay their
course no so in answer today if a
flagship were to walk away or decide
that it wasn't a joint venture fit for
them there's no cost to us incurred by
by their time in that world can we have
some corrected language in three point
one for the recommendation that reflects
the case that the business case would be
developed jointly by the district in
flexion that explores the opportunities
their joint venture with flagship would
create and then I think that accurately
describes the paper but I think the
confusion is set in because the
recommendation doesn't match the content
of the paper well are you happy with
that council plan
cancel Reba thank you very much chair I
mean I was with counselor Flemming on
that go okay so I think it is gone it's
not not completely clear that and I
would if I was you I would add an extra
to that because my question was going to
be what is the cost capped at because
there's paper the recommendation and
moment you could spend hundreds of
thousands you know on on developing
unknown after smiling and and would love
probably hundreds of thousands to spend
on proposals but um it yeah I would
suggest you is that but I'm not the
cabinet many my questions really are
staff my concern I know I appreciate
this is a paper that's asking for your
approval to move to a joint venture
which then will suggest something you
know for you to agree but you know we've
got a lot of staff working here and I've
just got a big concern that their roles
are protected and that we work well with
them throughout this process so I've
just got fear about that I'm wanting to
to look after our staff here and
secondly just want my common common
question about our housing stock is can
we ensure that whatever we're doing this
we ensure that we are moving towards
making sure every single home we have is
fully insulated and therefore can
provide and tenants with the cheapest
heating cost possible and just finally
the again from the environmental
implications it says there aren't any
I'm suspect that the absolute loads but
you know that's something I think might
need to be looked on the future thank
you very much chair I think the point
about capping the costs is it is a good
one
Gavin you mentioned ten thousand would
that be an appropriate cap yeah so the
cost wouldn't be any more than ten
thousand pounds so the cap is is ten
thousand in answer to the the other
question from from councillor Ebert
staffer
paramount in in this in terms of having
an understanding of what we're doing and
why we're doing it and being involved in
the development of that and whilst this
was a cabinet paper coming to you today
conscious that it would be in the public
domain and to give staff that
transparency we actually held an event
at Holiday Inn in its which two weeks
ago where we had everyone there to talk
about where the service was where it was
going and the reasons why we were
considering a joint venture and as part
of that we're developing as a result a
team charter we're developing some work
around the results of star survey and
actually working with officers to
understand how they want to be kept best
kept informed updated and involved in
the development of the business case and
that works already already began in the
last two weeks just that I think the
third question was around in the
environment I think it's the point that
this report there are no environmental
implications of of the decision making
in this yes there'll be naturally
environmental implications from looking
at the can capital and plant maintenance
program and the amount of investment
that we have to spend and how we best
spend that in reducing fuel poverty and
improving our homes so I would expect
that to be a part of the business case
going forward I was just going to add to
what Kevin said and just just to repeat
what he said earlier so that 10,000
pounds cap is for the entirety that
works so for mid Suffolk that cap is
5,000 pounds because obviously the
workers across the two districts and and
the other element is in relation to the
staffing specifically part of the work
that we expect to now happen in terms of
is there a potential here for a joint
venture and how might that look and how
might that work is exactly that staff in
question is - would the staff
cheapy transfer to somewhere or would
they remain on our books and exploring
all of those opportunities but just to
give you some reassurance the law fully
protects our staff in that regard come
what may in terms of their terms and
conditions but clearly that that would
be worked through as part of the work if
approved today in terms of exactly what
that would look like or could look like
cancel my tater I think Arthur's almost
introduced the sort of question that was
in my head because my understanding is
BMPs was created by amalgamating babies
external workforce with mid service
internal work for so those two are two
paying in similarly with a flagship
Group employs two paying in and they
were suitably new employees that come
into the new organization will have
their own new terms conditions so it
does sound like the could be for a
through small organisation tremendous
variety of terms conditions so assuming
that they charge every day which involve
day-in day-out through this process yes
speculating on what that might look like
in the same way that I speculated in
terms of what that might look like that
all needs to be worked through intensive
in terms of what they could could
actually be yes and keeping it simple
counselor field thank you I know it's
just in 421 paragraph 421 you know
there's got a bit information there
about the size of flagship group the
number of homes etc and it's moody
ratings etc there's nothing about rft
itself i wondered just how substantial
they are they presumably maintain 28,000
homes but it might be more or less so
what sort of size are they compared with
our own business do they rate really
well or you know our ratings have been
reducing or there's doing the same or
are they doing well that would be
certainly interesting the other point I
was concerned about is if we any view
yet as to what this joint venture would
look like it's a joint venture with
flagship to set up a new area other
thing that was just a question or was it
two we're essentially buying into their
operation rft and on that with those
thoughts in mind we got any idea of what
sort of capital investments we've been
needing tonight do they make we've got
six hours and home
they make 28,000 parts or whatever and
we make six thousand parts of all future
capital investments what happens if
there's a profit or a loss from the
business do we you know have it how do
we carry that is that all part of the
business case which is just yet to be
determined
okay thanks counselor field for those
questions just picking up some of the
points rft provides repairs and
maintenance services to the flagship
group AB so they're there for providing
repairs and maintenance to up to 28,000
homes rft were developed and introduced
about seven or eight years ago and I
think it's fair to say that in the
beginning there were challenges in
delivering that service for flagship
through our ft and not everything was
right went right on day one I think when
we were looking at our preferred partner
there is an acknowledgement that
actually they've been on a very similar
journey to the one that we find
ourselves on now but they find
themselves six seven years down the road
so actually if they've made potentially
made mistakes along the way
actually they're not going to make those
again so actually will benefit from
their knowledge and expertise in a way
that we can't do on our own in terms of
our ft and then providing services it's
not for me to sit here and and talk
about R of T and the services they
provide
what I can do is reassure you that as
part of the recent star survey one of
the questions that we asked residents
was to give us a net promoter score and
a net promoter score is is recognized
it's an industry standard across a whole
range of different set public and
private sectors our Net Promoter Score
so that's it for every person that would
promote you as a good landlord versus
everyone that would have a negative or
adverse experience of you and would
promote you negatively our Net Promoter
Score was 20 our ft and flagship are
operating with a net promoter school
of 4045 Plus at the moment so I think
that shows you that actually they're
delivering services that are receiving
far higher and far greater levels of
satisfaction than we are providing now
obviously some of the benefits of a
joint venture would be the economies of
scale so in comparison we're relatively
small but for example we procure
materials from the same supplier and
we've historically been looking at the
types of materials that flagship reviews
in comparison to our own in terms of
quality and cost so actually through the
joint venture there could be significant
economies of scale in terms of buying
more widgets in that regard as well as
as as the other benefits and one that
I've talked to members about
historically in that in the two
districts there are nearly seven
thousand baby or mid Suffolk council
homes in those same streets you will
find homes owned by Orwell housing by
flagship group by Suffolk Housing and
others and actually the economies of
scale come from the joint venture long
term where actually it could be that a
an officer might go into a Baber home or
been Suffolk home and repair the bath
but the net very next visit be going
into the flagship home because why is it
there's no sense in in staff traveling
from Norfolk down to repair a property
when we've got staff locally as well so
there are benefits you'll notice that
obviously part of the development of
Vista cases those financials and those
financials need to be sound for us and
for flagship group I don't have those
financials to present to you today
because this is very early stage this is
just a commitment to developing a
business case over the next few months
yeah just a quick one on a small one a
point of clarification I think if we are
going to change the wording of
recommendation 3.1 might we please you
lose the initial capitals on joint
venture I don't see what that tells us
it elevates
we all know what a joint venture is if
you're going to be talking about
flagship within recommendation anyway
it's obvious and I think capital initial
is elevated to give it a meaning that I
can't interpret so thank you one last
question
counsel Willem Thank You chair um do you
envisage that the joint venture might
operate outside of the flagship area and
is this is this a joint venture with rft
if so where do where do blue flame and I
think you said gas wave fit into that
because I can't get a feel for who
you're joining with and if rft have
other contracts might the mid suffer
famous staff or the present mid suffered
famous type B be operating somewhere in
Harford shear because our ft I've got
some work in Hartford [ __ ] it seems to
it could get could grow into a big a big
thing with our people a very small part
of it so in answer to that question the
joint venture would be with flagship
group flash it group owned a number of
subsidiaries or tackle companies and
part of development the business case
will be to develop what that joint
venture looks like as a legal entity
because obviously there are there was a
legal process that we'd have to go
through and which companies would form
part of that joint venture so I can't
sit here today to say it would be any
one of flagship subsidiaries other than
to say it would be with the flagship
group and as we develop the business
case we might find that there are
benefits of the joint venture
encompassing other other parts of the
flagship group but that's there there's
some legal and technical questions that
we all need to explore as we develop the
business case in answer to your other
question it depends on what the joint
venture looks like in terms of the
business case and
and what we ultimately achieve from this
so yes I've described a situation where
an officer may be repairing abate amid
Suffolk property and then repairing a
flagship property yes
flagship Group owned housing across the
whole of East Anglia so yes there I
guess there could be the opportunity
that that officers may work in in
different areas but we have we shouldn't
new site that actually we've got nearly
7,000 council homes that have to be
maintained have to be repaired have to
be improved and therefore the workforce
will be predominantly solely focused on
on that and and efficiencies are gained
through working in in new ways so I'm
looking at rewording paragraph 3.1 to
insert the word jointly after is
developed and after by officers to
insert oh babe er and mid Suffolk
district councils and flagship group so
that it reads that a business case is
developed jointly by officers of Baber
and mid Suffolk district councils and
flagship group which explores the
opportunities a joint venture in lower
case would create to deliver building
services happy with that councillors
and and I've just take advice on how to
would the paragraph about capping the
costs at ten thousand where that should
appear effectively I think you you are
saying that those costs will be captain
you had that indicated already by the
mother Ellen offices in terms of the
agreement that's in place so that would
be a within the minutes that the costs
are capped at ten thousand pounds in
total for the two districts you could
include it within recommendations if you
wish but I would suggest the minutes
probably sufficient
have a show of hands in favor unanimous
thank you carrot
item 11 looking at exclusion of public
which term includes the press to
consider whether pursuant to part 1 of
schedule 12a at the Local Government Act
1972 the public should be excluded from
the meeting for the business specified
below on the grounds that if the public
were present during these items it is
likely that there would be the
disclosure to them of exempt information
as indicated against each item the
authors of the report proposed to be
considered in part two of the agenda are
satisfied that the public interest in
maintaining the exemption outweighs the
public interest in disclosing the
information I propose can I have a
seconder please councillor Brewster
thank you happy to sir madam chairman
Oh show of hands - thank you
you
it's meeting is Monday the 4th of
November thank you very much
councillors meeting closed at 3:43 Suzie
Suzie